this coveted top diplomatic job is for
the first time going to a woman named
Karen Pierce is currently the UK's
ambassador to the UN known as a straight
talker she has four decades of foreign
service experience much needed at a
challenging time now we've left the
European Union I want to find out those
new opportunities and exploit them use
them develop them for the benefit of the
UK but also for the benefit of America
and hopefully find ways also to have
more people-to-people links as we do
that Pierce has been a strong presence
at the UN taking on Russia over issues
like Syria and the poisoning in the UK a
former Russian double agent sergey
skripnikov the crime in Salisbury would
be like Scotland Yard inviting in
Professor Moriarty so I don't think
that's a tenable way forward her
diplomatic skills are much needed at the
Washington DC embassy after the
controversial embarrassing exit of her
predecessor the last ambassador here was
of course Kim Derek who resigned last
year after leaked diplomatic cables
revealed that he characterized the Trump
administration as clumsy and inept
unsurprisingly Trump did not take this
well firing back on Twitter the whacky
ambassador that the UK foisted upon the
United States is not someone we are
thrilled with a very stupid guy
president Trump had recommended Nigel
Farage for the role now he has a hugely
respected and experienced woman if you
just kind of say is this a perfect
relationship made in heaven the answer
is no on the other hand ambassador
Pierce would not have risen to where she
is already would not be appointed if she
were not a great diplomat and so I think
one can expect her to figure out how to
operate in a Washington which is
anything but
normal the issue of Huawei will be among
her challenges with President Trump
reportedly apoplectic over the UK's
decision to allow the Chinese tech giant
to supply portions of its 5g wireless
network her biggest job will be
smoothing negotiations over the post
brexit trade deal all under the watch of
a most unpredictable US leader Amanda
Walker Sky News Washington